and
what is what does it even mean so one of
the things i think about a lot is
worlds with more than one temporal
dimension
it's very hard to think about one more
than one temporal dimension
so that's a really strong mental
exercise
of breaking the framework in which we
think because uh
most of the frameworks would have a
single temporal dimension right well
first of all most of the frameworks in
which we think would have no temporal
dimension and have pure
like in mathematics the differential
geometry that
riemann came up with in the 1800s
we don't usually talk about what we
would call split signature metrics
or lorentzian signature in fact if it
weren't for relativity this would be the
most obscure
topic out there almost all the work we
do is an euclidean signature and then
there's this one freakish case of
relativity theory in physics that uses
this one time and the rest
spatial dimensions fascinating
so it's usually momentary and just
looking at space
yes you know we have these three kinds
of
equations that are very important to us
we have elliptic
hyperbolic and parabolic right and so
the idea is
if if i'm chewing gum after eating
garlic bread
when i open my mouth and i've got
chewing gum between my lips
maybe it's going to form an elliptic
object called a minimal surface
then when i pop that and blow through it
you're going to hear a noise that's
going to travel to you by a wave
equation which is going to be hyperbolic
but then the garlic breath is going to
diffuse
towards you and you're eventually going
to be very upset with me according to a
heat equation which will be parabolic
so those are the three basic paradigms
for most of the work that we do
and a lot of the work that we do in
mathematics is elliptic
whereas the physicists are in the
hyperbolic case and i don't even know
what to do about more than one temporal
dimension because i think almost no one
studies that
i can't believe you just captured much
of modern physics
in the example of chewing gum i have an
off-color one which i chose not to share
but
hopefully the kids at home can imagine
okay so okay that is the place where we
come from
now if we want to arrive at a
possibility of breaking the frameworks
at with two versus zero temporal
dimensions how do we even begin to think
about well let's think about it as
you and i getting together in new york
city okay
so if you tell me uh eric i want to meet
you in new york city go to the corner
of i don't know 34th street
and third avenue and you'll find a
building on the northwest corner and go
up to the 17th floor
right so when we have third avenue
that's one coordinate 34th street that's
the second coordinate and go up to the
17th
and what time is that oh 12 noon all
right well now imagine that we traded
the ability to get up to a particular
height in a building it's all flat land
but
i'm going to give you two temporal cords
so meet me at 5 pm
and 12 noon at the corner of 34th and
3rd
that gets to be too mind-blowing i've
got two separate watches
and presumably that's just specifying a
single point
in those two different dimensions but
then being able to travel along those
dimensions
let me see your right hand
you have no watch on that yeah okay i'm
very concerned lex that you're going
through life
without a wrist watch that is my
favorite and most valued wrist watch i
want you to wear it
this guy is funnier than basically any
human on earth
that has been in my family for months
it's a fitbit now what i want you to
understand is
lex fritman is now in a position to live
in two spatial and two temporal
dimensions unlike the rest of us
i clearly am only fit for four four
spatial dimensions
so i'm frozen whereas you can double
move
i can double move which is funny because
this is set in
uh austin time yeah so it's 4 00 p.m and
this is set
in los angeles times well that's just
with an affine shift in mod 12
but my point is is that wouldn't that be
interesting if there were two separate
time skills and you had to coordinate
both of those but you didn't have to
worry about what floor of the building
because everything was on the ground
floor
okay that is the confusion that we're
having
and if you do one more show right then
they're gonna put a watch on your ankle
you're only going to have one spatial
dimension that you can move around but
my claim is is that all of these
are actually sectors of of my theory in
case
we're interested in that which is
geometric unity there is a two-two
sector
and a 3-1 and a 1-3 and a 0-4 and a 4-0
and all of these sectors have some
physical reality we happen to live
in a 1-3 sector but that's the kind of
thinking that we don't do when i say we
have to get off this planet people
imagine oh okay it's just einstein plus
some ability to break the law
you